uh
the ashwin mentioned of counting the
sink elements i really want to sort of
illustrate a technique in the message
passing model which is very powerful for
a number of applications um so this is a
joint work with uh yili xiaoming sun
chang wang and xinjiang
um
so
earlier in the workshop you you've seen
this k-party number in hand uh model
just to quickly recap um here we have uh
k players p1 through pk
who each have their own private input uh
x1 through xk respectively
and their goal is to compute some
function um
f of their inputs
and we'd like to minimize
typically the randomized communication
complexity of this task
in this model we have point-to-point
communication so
i'm going to allow every pair of players
to be able to talk to each other
and
so the model is well-defined we also
have that the protocol transcript
determines who speaks next okay so
the protocol determines who starts and
each message determines who speaks next
so this is the k-party number in hand
model
one thing that's often useful is to uh
introduce the notion of a coordinator c
so this could be one of the players or
it could be a new player
and what we do is uh we route all
communication through this coordinator
okay so um
this only changes the communication uh
by a factor of two so if pi wants to
send a message to pj
now the player
you know tells the coordinator to send
the message to pj so the message gets
sent twice
and also um uh
there's an additional uh word per
message uh where the player since the
player has to you know specify who the
recipient of the message is but for this
talk we're going to ignore these these
factors
okay so
yeah there are a number of problems
looked at in these models
so database problems
you have a database which is partitioned
across multiple servers and they might
want to estimate statistics of this
database such as distinct elements or
frequency moments
linear algebraic problems maybe everyone
has a matrix and you want to know if the
sum of the matrices is invertible
or maybe you want to
solve a linear system which involves the
sum of these matrices
graph problems maybe everyone has a
disjoint subset of edges of a graph
and you'd like to know if the graph is
say connected or bipartite
okay so these are some problems
so for this talk what i'm going to do is
focus
on a distributional communication
problem
uh which i'll call uh some disjointness
and um yes i won't get into the details
of how to apply this uh to these
applications or sort of variants of this
uh problem which are more useful for
some of the applications
um
okay so
let me just say some notation here
so uh for sets s and t
define the disjointness function the
standard
notion of disjointness so this j of st
is one if um the sets s and t intersect
and it's uh it's zero otherwise
okay
um
so i'll use this throughout the talk
so what is the sum disjointness problem
that i'm talking about
so it's the following okay
i'll describe it here but what you're
going to think about is is having the
coordinator
trying to solve a disjointness instance
between each of the players
now let me describe this uh
more formally
so it's a distributional problem
so let s be a random subset of one
through n
and you can think of this as being the
input to the coordinator
okay
and now we're going to
define how we give the inputs to the
remaining players
so independently for each of the players
with probability one half
we give the player pi a random set ti
subject to the condition that it
intersects s
and with remaining probably one half we
give it a random set ti so that
um it doesn't intersect set s
um so i didn't really specify
how you choose uh ti condition on it
intersecting s or not condition on
intersecting s but let's ignore that for
now i'll get i'll mention that a little
bit later
so this is uh
these are the inputs to the problem and
what is the problem
so the problem is it's a promise problem
and what they'd like to do is they want
to know if the number of sets that
intersect s
is at least k over 2 plus root k
or at most k over 2 minus root k
okay now note by uh standard
anti-concentration of the binomial
distribution one of these cases is going
to happen with large
constant probability
and you know given that you're in one of
these cases you'd like to know which one
and so the result that i'll describe
here is that you can show that the
randomized communication complexity of
this task
is omega n times k
okay so n is the uh
um sort of the universe size of a
disjointness instance and k the number
of players
and note that all these disjointness
instances you know are heavily
correlated right they're all using the
same set s
of the coordinator
okay
so
um
to let me try to show this uh an outline
of the proof
so to study this problem let's introduce
a simpler problem called the gap
threshold problem
okay
so uh in this problem again in this
k-party number and hand model player pi
now only holds a bit zi
okay instead of a set
and the zi are independent um fair coin
tosses across the k players
and what they'd like to do is decide the
following
is the sum of the coin tosses the sum of
these bernoulli one-half
variables at least k over 2 plus root k
or at most k over 2 minus 4k
okay and as before otherwise we don't
care it's a distributional problem
okay
so
can we show a lower bound for this
problem so intuitively
you know
omega-k bits of communication
seems like a lower bound for this
problem
a natural protocol would be to try to
sample players
and look at the sum of the of the
samples and use that to try to estimate
the
the overall sum so this doesn't work
this needs k samples
but how do you formally prove uh
this lower bound
okay
so
um
so we're going to
use the rectangle property of
communication
to show this
this claim which is very important for
the proof
it's the following
so the players run this protocol a key
party protocol for this simpler gap
threshold problem
and at the end of the protocol
execution there's some transcript tau
which includes all the messages and the
output
and the claim is that these bits
z1 through zk
are independent
even conditioned on the value of the
transcript
okay so they started off as independent
bernoulli won half variables and after
you run this protocol i claim they're
still independent though they're no
longer
fair coin tosses
so why is this
so let's just assume for now that the
players are deterministic uh we're
proving a lower bound by yalis principle
i'll i'll mention
um how to extend this to randomize which
is sometimes useful in the context of uh
larger problems but let's just assume
they're deterministic for now
so what is the input vector um
uh to this problem
so everyone has a bit so the input is
just this vector z
uh this bit string of length k
okay and everyone has a id coin toss so
the distribution on the inputs is
uniform
and the claim um you know this is a
property of communication that you take
this input space zero one to the k and
you cut it up into combinatorial
rectangles each transcript tile
corresponds to one of these rectangles
and these rectangles have this nice uh
product structure so
one of these rectangles s it looks like
s1 cross s2 cross sk
where in this case each si is in 0 1 is
a subset of 0 1 since the input
is a bit
okay in particular si can be the full
set 0 1 or 0 or 1.
okay this is a simple
um setting
um so now
since these coin tosses zi were
independent to start with
now let's condition on the value of a
transcript so we condition on the set s
so what we have
is conditioned on this we have a random
pre-image
of this set s
and because of this product structure
what this means is actually that
you know exactly the statement that i'm
trying to show that the zi's are
independent condition on this transcript
right so because of this product
structure what happens is that uh each
zi condition on the transcript is either
still a random bit or it's fixed to zero
or fixed to one
yeah okay okay so this is a an important
property
um
so now let's try to yeah so where are we
we're trying to prove this uh omega k
lower bound for this gap threshold
problem
everyone has this uh fair coin toss
and yeah the coordinator is trying to
decide if the sum is greater than k over
2 plus root k word most k over 2 minus
root k
and now as i just said that by
independence of these bits conditioned
on the transcript
this is equivalent to fixing some of the
zi's to be zero one or to be bernoulli
one half after the
uh the protocol execution okay so how
can we use this uh this property
so uh i'll just present a short sequence
of lemmas which capture the the ideas
for this
so the first letter i want to call the
unbiased conditional expectation lemma
and what this says is the following
so there's some notion of a transcript
distribution where there's an input
distribution then i run this
deterministic protocol and i get a
distribution on transcripts
and what i'm saying is with probably
two-thirds over the choice of a
transcript from this distribution
the expectation of these the sum of
these condition bits
is not too far from what it was before
it started off as k over 2 and now i'm
claiming the expectation is within say
100 root k of k over 2.
now why is this i mean this is certainly
not true uh for all transcripts i'm just
saying with good probability
uh this happens why is this true
well one way to see it is the fault is
the following
uh way so consider any transcriptile
these are just bits these the eyes
condition on tao so the variance is at
most k
okay of this sum
um
and uh
now um
basically uh if i condition on tao and i
look at these bits since the variance is
at most k i'm going to deviate from my
whatever my expectation is by about by
about root k
so one way of sampling an input is to
first sample a transcript and then
sample an input condition on the
transcript now we know if we just sample
an input then the sum of the zi's is
going to be very close to k over 2 with
constant probability
but if this statement did not hold then
basically i could sample a transcript
and now i'm 100 root k away from k or 2
and then i could sample an input
condition on that transcript and by
chebychev's inequality i'm close to that
expectation
which means that you know with good
probability i'm
50 root k away from k over 2
for one of the inputs
which can't happen right because we know
the inputs are binomially distributed so
they're close to k over 2.
okay so this is saying that
you know for typical transcript the
expectation remains close to what it was
uh
before the conditioning
this is the first lemma
and note that that limit doesn't didn't
even use the communication was small or
anything like
that the second lemma does use the fact
that i'm going to assume the
communication is little of k and get a
contradiction
and this i call lots of randomness after
conditioning
so here is if the communication total
communication is little of k
um
then
for most of these indices uh uh you know
so for them for a typical transcript for
most of the indices i
we have that the conditioned uh random
variable the eye condition on tao is
still a fair coin toss
right now this just follows by counting
right we're partitioning this input
space zero one to the k into pieces if
we fixed all the bits we would have
way too many pieces and the
communication is log of the number of
pieces we would get a k lower bound
so
okay so
yeah so we have these two properties the
expectation is close to k over two and
most of these uh are still uh iid
bernoulli one half
okay
so let's uh you know condition on the
towel satisfying these two lemons which
happens with good constant probability
and so now the whole proof is just uh
based on a
an anti-concentration observation
so we fix such a tau
and now let's look at the following
right so
most of these bits conditioned on tau
are still
you know fair coin tosses
so they have a lot of deviation
i mean so in particular you know with
probability uh a small constant
probability
0.01
these things will be more than 100 root
k away from whatever their expectation
is in either direction
well that's a problem right because the
expectation is within
100 root k of k over 2 and these things
are deviating by more than 100 root k in
either direction
you know so in particular they're
k over 2 plus root k or k 2 minus root k
with some small constant probability
but you know the output is just based on
this transcript and so the protocol
has to fail with this probability this
.001
right
so
so basically with good probability i
sample a transcript
and condition on that then i have this
good probability of this reasonable
probability of failing so the protocol
if it uses um
you know
much less than k communication fails
with some constant probability
okay
so
um
right
okay so let me just uh so so this is
this is actually the whole proof for the
deterministic distributional case
um
let me just mention a simple uh
extension so when the players have uh
their own private randomness
uh the proof generalizes you just think
of the randomness as being part of the
input
and now you know it's the randomness
together with uh the input bit
and the generalization of this so now
you know the zi's conditional and
transcript are no longer just primarily
uh one half uh but what you can show is
an analogous statement that for most of
the you know for a typical transcription
for most of the indices the entropy is
considerably reduced right it started
off as one and it goes down to something
very small
so
a correct protocol must satisfy this
property
um
okay
so
now let's go back to this original
problem that we're interested in which
is the sum disjointness problem
okay
so yeah you know recall these input sets
ti intersect some set s
we chose this random set s to give to
the coordinator and um
now let's let's do the and we then we
chose this ti's independently to
intersect s with probably one half
um so let's think of the following let's
think of embedding this gap threshold
problem inside of this some disjointness
problem
okay so suppose i just have these
uniform random bits z1 through zk
that are you know that are inputs to the
gap uh threshold problem
what i'm going to do is uh for each
player i
p i if z i is equal to one
then i'm going to choose a random set t
i
so that
the disjointness so that ti intersects s
okay
and if z is equal to zero
then
i choose ti so it does not intersect s
so what i'm doing is i'm encoding the
inputs to this gap threshold problem as
the outputs of these k distortness
instances okay
and recall earlier i mean what is this
problem we're trying to figure out if
the number of sets which intersects s is
at least k over 2 plus root k or at most
k over 2 minus root k
or equivalently in this notation
we're trying to figure out if the sum of
these zi's these output bits is at least
k over two plus root k or at most k over
two minus root k yeah let's specify how
you select them to intersect
yeah so i i won't get in let me just say
how you do it so you do it uh in the in
a distribute in in rasbora's
distribution basically so base so what
you do
is you choose them to intersect uh at a
unique random position of s
and um and they actually have size n
over four instead of n over two but i'm
just i'll use that result as a black box
uh basically
so so um
yeah so so in this notation
this is what they're trying to solve
okay so i mean i can use this uh
so this is a protocol
um which uh is solving
this problem
and by the previous analysis a correct
protocol for this
satisfies the property that the
probability of our transcripts
for typical and from for most choices of
indices the entropy of zi is reduced
condition on the transcript this was
what we proved about gap threshold
okay and we saw that the output of this
problem is solving this gap threshold
problem
okay so this is sort of the embedding
argument
okay but these eyes are the output bits
of these disjointness instances
right so what's happening here is most
of these dystonia instances are actually
being solved by the protocol i can run
the protocol and i can look at the
transcript and i can figure out these
bits zi the output bits
okay so this is uh
now where we um at this point we're
gonna try to get a contradiction by
reducing to a two-player problem
okay so we have this property
and now suppose the overall
communication were much less than k
times n
okay so then by averaging
there's a player pi so that typically
the communication between the
coordinator and p i is much less than n
okay
and moreover you know just by a union
bound since for typical transcript most
of these uh output bits uh zi have their
entropy reduced
so this player pi has that this hdi
condition on tau is uh is small with
large uh probability so what we've done
is we found a player for which the
transcript typically
reveals the output bit of the
disjointness instance uh between the
coordinator and that player and moreover
the communication with that player is
small
so that should suggest you know these
are two players in this k player network
this should suggest the way of proving a
lower bound and it does
so
the idea is to uh now reduce to this
two-player problem
so consider uh
um
let the so you have two players in a
disjointness problem and let those two
players be identified with the
coordinator and this player pi that we
fixed on the previous slide
okay so what they do is um so let me
just say so uh if the coordinator has
some input set to this two-player
disjointness problem that becomes the
set s that we said we could think about
as the coordinator having
and the player pi's input is this uh ti
okay
but the nice thing here is that
this coordinator i mean there are only
two players now but the coordinator can
pretend like they're k players
and what it can do is using its input
set it can sample the inputs to all the
remaining players right how did we def
how did we give the inputs to these
remaining players we said independently
with probably one half i choose it to
intersect the the coordinator set and
with probably one half it doesn't
intersect the coordinator set so the
coordinator can generate all the inputs
for all the remaining players
and now they can run the k player
protocol
but i mean the point is here you know
messages between the the the coordinator
and players pj for j not equal to i they
can all be simulated by local
computation there's no actual
communication
right so the only communication is
between the coordinator and the ith
player
and
if this communication is low of n this
contradicts
distributional lower bounds for the
disjointness problem
okay it makes sense
okay so um
yeah so
uh
yeah that's an example of how reducing
to two players and an example of uh
using composition
um and
so let me just conclude
so
this is a composition technique
for proving lower bounds here which is
quite useful for
problems like estimating distinct
elements
in this model there are very other nice
techniques
by
riverman at all
and rhodum
and others which look at k-party uh
disjointness in this message passing
model which is a a different notion than
the disjointness instance that we looked
at here um there's also a symmetrization
technique of philips at all which this
sort of implicitly builds upon
i mean which it builds upon
um
there are many uh tight lower bounds for
problems in this model so statistical
problems
graph problems and linear algebra
problems a lot of these have been
resolved
and let me just mention uh
some future directions so i don't think
rounds versus communication is very well
understood in this model uh at this
point
so that's one thing uh another a very
nice work of um rkd uh
jay kumar and
afriruta is for topology sensitive
problems so instead of allowing all
players to be able to talk to each other
in a point-to-point fashion
there's some topology and you get
communication bounds that depend on that
topology
so that's all thanks
questions
can you say a few words about how it
applies to the problem of counting
distinct words
uh yeah so okay so for that problem um
everyone has uh
has a database and they want to know
i put all these databases together and i
want to know is the number of distinct
elements i want to get a say one plus
epsilon relative approximation to the
number of distinct elements
number of distinct records in this
database and for that problem you can
prove
k over epsilon squared lower bound where
k is the number of players and epsilon
is this approximation factor
and uh the one of repsol in fact squared
factor maps to this n in this
disjointness setting
and there's also a
variant of this
threshold sum problem you need which is
not checking if the majority uh is
you know is biased away or biased
towards
you you need a threshold at a very
different level
not not even a constant factor times k
but a very low
level and you can also generalize this
to get lower bounds for that and um
and sort of what happens here is this um
this yeah this k over two plus root k
this translates into um
uh
the root sort of the root k is giving
you the approximation factor this gap
translates to a one plus epsilon
approximation if you set all these
parameters appropriately but
yeah it's very
high level intuition but